not for nine billion dollars don't worry
i don't want to kiss you
if you watched icarly from the very
first episode you probably never would
have guessed how far sam and freddie's
relationship would go
from i hate you to i love you creator
dan schneider and nickelodeon gave fans
of the series the romance ride of their
life and for many viewers
seti was probably their very first ship
get ready to relive this epic and very
unique love story because we put
together an
entire timeline of their seattle and la
romance for
all your nostalgic needs buckle up never
said i hate you
yeah you have most people remember
icarly as the witty series that followed
three teens on their journey to internet
fame
but icarly was way more than just a show
about a web series
if you told us all the dramatic not to
mention romantic moments that would
eventually happen in carly's attic turn
studio
we probably wouldn't believe you i mean
who would have guessed that an innocent
nickelodeon show would turn out to
feature some iconic
love stories but it wasn't exactly a
fairy tale for these two teens in fact
freddy actually started off the series
obsessed with carly and when we say
obsessed we mean he
basically stalked carly from his
neighboring apartment
literally from the very first episode
i'm in love with
you you just want to be friends and i'm
totally cool living with that constant
pain
can we really blame him though he did
have a pretty
unique upbringing but carly was nothing
but a good sport and without freddie
icarly would definitely not have been a
reality
but freddie's love for carly wasn't the
only thing in the way of an epic romance
with sam
in fact for most of the series their
personalities is what divided them
with their classic greeting being i hate
you they were definitely classified as
frenemies
whether she was throwing insults i
always had a feeling it came from circus
people
drawing pictures of tigers eating him or
giving him ginormous wedgies
sam was nothing but positive that they
did not get along
in fact during earlier seasons the
closest they came to liking one another
was probably
when sam had to pretend to have a crush
on freddy but to do that she had to hide
his face underneath a paper bag
well how can i pretend to have a crush
on freddy if i'm looking at his face
little did she know that the crush would
soon actually become a reality
in good frenemy fashion the two were
always pulling devious pranks on one
another
remember when freddy handcuffed sam to
gibby
give me the key give her the key only if
she promises
but sam took it a step too far in this
season episode
after overhearing freddie's heart to
heart with carly i think it's kind of
sweet that you haven't kissed anyone yet
it's not sweet it's lame sam decides to
spill the beans about freddy never
having had his first kiss
on air freddy's never kissed a girl
never not once she soon realizes that
she may have crossed a line when freddy
gets seriously made fun of both at
school and online
the plus side to the prank is that it
actually got her to open up
viewers got to see that sam wasn't as
cold-hearted as she liked to tell people
in order to make things right during the
next airing of icarly sam put on a brave
face got in front of the camera and
admitted
i've never kissed anyone and then
proceeded to threaten everyone who even
thought of making fun of her
classic she may not be cold-hearted but
she still is sam
off camera though sam got even more
vulnerable in the same episode
sam follows freddie to the rooftop to
apologize again but something even more
shocking than sam saying sorry happens
after a very awkward conversation the
two friends decide that they can easily
fix the whole
never been kissed issue just to get it
over with just to get it over with
and decide to smooch it out it may have
been awkward but they definitely didn't
hate it
good work thank you you too it's at this
point in the series that things get
juicy
the fake crush from earlier on isn't so
fake anymore
we all know sam doesn't exactly deal
well with feelings and the rooftop
rendezvous came with a little more than
just a first kiss story
viewers got a glimpse at how she's
feeling when sam accidentally walks in
on carly and freddie slow dancing
while it may not have been much she was
definitely feeling jealous at this point
i mean longing looks quietly sneaking
out she
already had it bad fans of seti finally
got their long-awaited confirmation
in the episode i omg stuck in a lockdown
overnight at school
the gangs spend the time working on
their end-of-year semester projects
freddie sam and their friend brad's
project conveniently happens to be an
app called moodface that can tell you
how people are feeling
when they test it out on sam her emotion
comes back as in love
you heard right in love so what's her
mood
ah it's uh it's inconclusive
just like freddy we were all blown away
because brad is in the room at the time
carly and freddie assume she's in love
with him
in love with brad
he even figures that's the reason she
wanted to do the project with them
in the first place like any meddling
best friends they try to set the two up
i'm not coming back but sam is not
having any of it
in fact she gets pretty angry with the
two of them because only she knows the
real truth about who she's
actually in love with bretty follows sam
to let her know that she should
definitely go for brad and encourages
her to share her feelings
she does definitely go for it but it
doesn't involve brad
instead she takes his advice because you
never know if the person you like is
gonna like you back
everyone feels that way pulls freddy in
and
kisses him sorry that's cool
if you thought sam was dramatic before
kissing freddy you probably weren't
surprised when she checked herself into
the hospital for loving him
that's right sam literally thought
something was wrong with her for falling
in love with freddy
i mean talk about a hit to the ego for
him carly tries to help sam by
explaining to her that there's nothing
wrong with what she's feeling
but sam just doesn't want to hear it you
think that just because you like freddie
don't say it out loud her friends and
fans weren't going to give up that
easily though
in fact things only got worse after her
ordeal in the hospital
their ship name seti was created thanks
to icarly fans
and like every conflict in this series
things get sorted out during a heated
icarly episode
while questions from fans asking why
seti hasn't happened yet keep rolling in
freddy gets a little frustrated himself
when he took center stage in front of
the camera we all definitely knew things
were getting serious
freddie hated the camera after all he
was more of the behind the scenes guy
but nobody asked me how i feel yes she
admitted to being in love with him
yes she checked herself into the
hospital over it but does freddie even
like her back
at this point sam is convinced they've
returned back to their old ways and this
is just another way to get back at her
on the air but freddie quickly assures
her with a spontaneous kiss right in the
middle of the hospital's very mediocre
cafeteria
nevertheless it was the seti moment we
and the fictional icarly fans were all
waiting for
you mean that the next logical step was
of course for them to date and
surprisingly things started off pretty
smoothly
i'd love to baby they cuddled kissed
went on dates and sam
even admitted to freddie the first time
she realized she liked him
it was the moment after she pushed him
in front of a bike and he was laying on
the floor hurt
i don't know you look kind of cute
no it's kind of romantic
right unfortunately things don't stay
perfect forever
in fact things go bad just after a few
episodes
while there's no doubt that freddy and
sam love each other their personalities
are still drastically
drastically different and carly quickly
notices that for a couple they're
actually spending very little time
together she convinces them to try and
learn to love each other's hobbies
but when freddy tries to take sam to his
model train club
things get difficult when the rest of
the club tries to throw sam out because
of the no girls allowed rule
no girls allowed to train club meetings
this doesn't exactly go over well with
sam
and she squeezes freddie's friend's
wrist until he passes out
if that wasn't reason enough to get
freddie kicked out of the club
sam causes an explosion in the middle of
their track which sends them packing for
good
in the end blowing up trains wasn't what
broke the two of them up but it
definitely made them reflect on their
relationship
the two eavesdropped on carly lecturing
her brother spencer about forcing his
relationship with his current girlfriend
and realizing that they might be doing
the exact same thing
i don't know be friends or something but
stop pretending you can be boyfriend and
girlfriend when you both know it's just
weird and wrong
the breakup is even more heartbreaking
because the two still
love one another but they don't part
ways without one last makeout session of
course
want to break up at midnight that works
okay
after their breakup the carly freddy and
sam love triangle sparks up again and
leaves fans with the question of whether
freddy loves carly or sam
in a later episode when no one is dating
sam calls freddy and says
i gotta talk to you about something
important freddie thinks it's that she
wants to get back together and while
things don't escalate from that
conversation
it's super obvious that the two of them
would rekindle their relationship
in a heartbeat talk about angst this
series doesn't end with a clear answer
on whether or not the two would end up
together
again actually sam and freddie never
actually got a proper goodbye
instead freddie and carly share a kiss
before she heads off to europe leaving
freddie alone in seattle
so i'm gonna get my bags and head
downstairs why don't i help you with
those bags yeah that'd be nice
so does that mean freddy and carly are
the two that end up together
not exactly freddy and sam's romance
didn't end when icarly did
sam's spin-off show sam and cat actually
documented a whole episode that featured
freddy
in the episode sam's los angeles
roommate cat also known as ariana grande
calls freddy and fakes that sam got into
a huge accident
sam got run over yeah it's real bad you
know bleeding gums fractured bones
broken buttocks freddie drops everything
to make the trip down to la frantically
worried about sam
but it was all a prank on cat's part in
order to get back at sam
after the whole ordeal was sorted and
freddie manages to catch himself before
almost admitting he loves sam freddie
ends up in the hospital where sam
asks him out on a date and he agrees we
sadly never get to see the date
we never do get an answer on either
carly or sam and cat about who freddie
actually loved more but considering the
last we saw of the two
they were making plans to go out it
probably means something
fans have been begging creator dan
schneider and even freddie's actor
nathan kress for years for a definite
answer
nathan even made an appearance on the
nickelodeon show game shakers where the
squad tracked him down to get answers
about whether seti or credi were the
real deal
and since it was never established on
the show i don't know which girl freddie
loved more
it seems possible that we may never know
who he really loved
unless maybe we get a reboot hint hint
nickelodeon
freddie and sam's relationship may be
extremely unconventional but we wouldn't
trade it for the world
and while we never got confirmation on
whether or not they were
end game we're pretty sure freddie
dropping everything to help sam in la
says it all were you a study shipper do
you think freddy loved sam or carly more
what do you think happened after their
encounter in la feel free to share your
opinion
and what you think in the comment
section below and don't forget to hit
that subscribe button for more videos
just like this one
logging off